il constitue l'une des principales
richesses des 270 mille habitants de
l'archipel
en 2018 le nickel représentait 7% du pib
local enjeu économique pour la nouvelle
calédonie le minerai se retrouve au
coeur des débats entre les
indépendantistes et les loyalistes et
celles à venir d'une usine de nickel est
située dans la province sud qui
cristallise les tensions
ce complexe minier appartient au
brésilien vale et emploie 1300 salariés
et 1500 sous traitants faute de
repreneur cette usine pourrait fermer
ses portes d'ici à la fin de l'année une
fermeture synonyme de catastrophe pour
l'archipel
la fermeture de l'usiné du sud serait un
véritable cataclysme par effets
successifs de ricochet c'est tout
l'écosystème économique qui serait
menacé
opposé au rachat de cette usine par des
capitaux étrangers les indépendantistes
milite pour une reprise du site par une
société d'économie mixte qui gère déjà
un complexe dans la province nord on
souhaite avoir la maîtrise de notre
ressource
parce qu'actuellement presque tous les
titres miniers sont détenus par des
multinationales avec le partenariat de
la france notre projet politique se base
nécessairement sur la valorisation de
cette ressource qui reste le poumon
économique du pays
de leur côté les loyalistes partisans du
non à l'indépendance estime la prise en
charge de ses usines trop lourdes pour
l'économie locale
les indépendantistes considère que
l'intéressé de nationaliser les
entreprises sauf qu'il y à déjà plus de
mille milliards de dettes cumulées
nous on considère que nos collectivités
sont incapables de gérer ce type d'
usine un bras de fer au centre de ce
deuxième scrutin sur l'indépendance du
caillou un scrutin auquel la chine
devrait prêter attention
situé à 8600 36 km de nouméa contre plus
de 16 mille kilomètres pour paris pékin
pourrait voir dans une éventuelle
indépendance de l'archipel un moyen
d'étendre un peu plus son influence dans
le pacifique